what does this feel like this has been
an adaptation that has been talked about
for so many years now we're here we're
at the Vermeer how do you describe it
Neil driven is probably going to use
this uh word a lot tonight but it is
very fitting this is surreal I remember
the guy that walked into an audition and
saw a character on the page and that
character became a role that I got to
play for a long time and now here I am
seeing that character not only on a
bigger screen but played by an
incredible actor every one of these
people that are in this show have
dedicated themselves with such skill and
talent and passion it's it's it seems
weird to say but I'm proud of them but
I'm proud to be here look right here did
you have that moment with Pedro where
you're like
that's Joel yeah and what's funny enough
is it we had these great moments on set
but it was when I finally got to see it
on screen I was like wow I all I wanted
from this role was I wanted someone to
teach me something about the character
that I missed and that's exactly what
Petra did what do you feel like he
taught you about the character that's
the secret between he and I
have had some moment
we have more but also you know being a
part of this for so long and then
stepping onto the set you're also a part
of it playing a different character what
was that moment like for you it was a
playground it was so much fun for me to
be able to first of all the set that I'm
normally on is a big gray room with
bright lights and I'm wearing a weird
suit I've got a camera right here on my
face so to be in this beautiful set
um this beautiful location with the crew
of hundreds of people I had to bench
myself it was it was a dream come true
I'm ready to be heard again yes you will
be hurt we're coming for your heart Big
Time thank you oh thank you so much Troy
good to see you cheers